(chattering)
- What we think about in
the examples that are...
(cheering)
- Very good job.
- Okay.
- The power of the social brain
has been totally underestimated.
It's a driving force in learning.
It's the gateway to cognition.
We have evidence that the social brain
is operating to assist learning
throughout the lifespan.
So let's think about human babies.
We know in the development of language
that there's a very important period
between six months and 12 months of age
where babies are mastering
the sounds of language.
So we've done experiments
in which babies are exposed
to a foreign language right
at that critical moment.
(speaking in Mandarin)
- They're listening to a Mandarin speaker
when they're growing up
in an English family.
What we've demonstrated is
that if a baby at nine months
has 12 sessions of play
with a live human speaker,
they learn so well that they're
statistically equivalent
to the babies in the foreign country
who've been listening for 10 months;
however, if the babies are
exposed to the same material
at the same time, same room, same dosage,
but not exposed to a live human being
and instead on a beautiful
DVD, they stare at it,
you think they're learning,
but the brain tests following exposure
show that the kids in the
machine group learned nothing.
The babies in the live
group learned so well
they matched the babies
in the foreign country.
- Eli, when there was...
- To be 101.
- So there's something
about being in the presence
of another human being
and watching the eyes and
watching the movements
and paying attention to
what that person is doing.
That social context is
extremely important to learning.
- Because, I mean...
- Get the chunks of candy.
- We can see it in school-aged children
who use the social brain
when they're interacting
with one another to collaborate,
when they're studying how
another person goes at it,
when they're watching the
eyes even unconsciously
of their study partner to work
towards a solution together.
In fact, I like to say the social brain
gates human learning.
That without the
motivation and information
provided by the social brain,
learning just doesn't
take off in the same way
that it does when the
social brain is engaged.